وهو ذكرى النكبة الفلسطينية
للاحتفال بالذكرى الرابعة
البلاد كيم جونغ اون اشرف على
اطلاق نوع جديد من الاسلحة
الاسرائيلية بسبب حرب موسكو ضد
اوكرانيا والرئيس بوتين يطالب
دليل على ان التعاون الاقليمي
ممكن وليس مجرد اعلان. عن اي
خيانة جديدة. تعرضت فلسطين لخيبة
جديدة من دولة الامارات. بينما
وحليفتها الجنوبية وينذر باقتراب
حرب كارثية على جميع الاطراف.
اعلام اسرائيلية ان طائرات
اماراتية ستشارك لاول في التاريخ
الاوكرانية وسط تبادل لاتهامات
لاعتداءات بين الطرفين. كيم
يتناقشون يا ترى. علاقات متوترة.
توتر للعلاقات الروسية
المقبل. وقالت جمعية الطيارين
الاسرائيليين ان هذا العرض الجوي
المزعج. في كوريا الشمالية قالت
وكالة الانباء المركزية ان زعيم
في عرض جوي سيقام احتفالا بما
يسمى يوم الاستقلال الاسرائيلي
وذاك تشتد المعارك بين قوات
موسكو وقوات كييف على الاراضي
يتعرض المسجد الاقصى والمقاومة
الفلسطينية لهجمات عنيفة من
الولايات المتحدة وكوريا
الجنوبية وهو ما يخيف امريكا
تجربة بيونج يانج بالتزامن مع
تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة بين
المحتل وبعد خيبة قديمة بتطبيع
ابو ظبي مع تل ابيب اعلنت وسائل
فاكثر. ترامب ينصب فخه عمدا
لخلفه بيض ويجعله في موقف صعب.
للفلسطينيين. العلاقات بين
اسرائيل وروسيا تتوتر اكثر
تطبيع نتحدث يا سادة وعن اي طعن
في الظهر لفلسطين الجريحة
والسبعين لاعلان قيام دولة
اسرائيل. في الخامس من مايو
تحذر من صدام غير مقصود مع
الناتو مرشحة فرنسية تريد ايقاف
التكتيكية الموجهة بهدف تعزيز
القدرات النووية للبلاد وتأتي
الغرب لخطة جديدة تهدف الى وضع
حد للتجاوز الروسي. وبين هذا
بناء المساجد وتركيا تنفذ عملية
خاطفة في العراق بينما يستعد
الرئيس الاوكراني ينبه العالم
بالاستعداد للنووي الروسي موسكو
زعيم كوريا عاد ليزعج جيرانه
بتجارب جديدة واخطر من السابق.
والامارات لا تكتفي بالتطبيع مع
اسرائيل وتتجه لخيانة اكبر
اسرائيل